vous le savez on est ensemble jusqu'à
plus soif 1 dans un instant y aura à
prendre au lycée à poil
je voudrais revenir sur un truc vous
avez vu parce que je vous raconte tout
18 juin c'est tombé aujourd'hui je vous
racontais tout ce qui se passe franck
appietto m'appelle ce matin notre
président de ses mythes je dis toute la
vérité aux téléspectateurs il me dit
qu'on avait prévu de terminer la saison
le 18 juin et il me dit est ce que tu
penses que tu peux faire une semaine de
plus voilà avec les équipes et cetera
jusqu'au 25 jeudi
j'ai demandé à mes équipes et mes
équipes voilà voulait vraiment parce
qu'ils ont travaillé pendant tout le
confinement ils doivent travailler sur
la saison prochaine et donc on arrêtera
la saison le 18 juin
voilà on la demandait à francs capitaux
c'était voilà donc voilà on s'est mis
d'accord avec le président de sce vite
notre ami voilà donc à partir du 22 18
juin donc dû ce sera la dernière le
jeudi 18 juin et je vous le dis on est
en train de préparer des trucs de fou
pour la dernière bien entendu il y aura
à prendre ou à laisser spécial attendu
mais à partir du 22 donc il y aura une
nouvelle émission c'est une best-of tu
sais les best-of de tous les prime times
qu'on a fait chronologiquement ça veut
dire du premier revient jusqu'au dernier
avec toute une histoire voilà les chéris
voilà les équipes parce qu'elles ont
travaillé pendant tout le confinement
également même de chez eux voilà donc
forcément voilà on a envie et pour doit
préparer la saison prochaine de tpm paix
qui va être une très très grosse saison
parce qu'il va les voir bien sûr toute
l'équipe que vous voyez là qui sera
reconduite mais en plus des nouveautés
et en plus bien entendu des choses
encore voilà où dit on est en train de
travailler bouder sur quelque chose
aussi pour tpm paix ou lui voilà je vous
raconte un petit peu je racontais un
petit peu tout en en train de travailler
bouder sur un programme avec un enfant à
eux
voilà pour tpm paix parce que ça a
cartonné qu'elle aille avec un enfant de
confinement et papa et bouder c'est
l'idée de bouder je vous dis la vérité
et le papa et son fils est donc en train
de travailler sur ça avec booder